[Music]
so we're 16.65
pretty pretty uh high rated 1647 is our
opponent let's go e4 and we're mostly
still meeting okay so c5 and we've been
playing the smith mora with a lot of
success in in the speedrun let's
continue that practice
and ooh and accepted smith mora let's go
okay e5 now i've actually seen this move
a lot at this level uh which is new to
me because i mean it's a very
anti-positional move it weakens the d5
square tremendously black does sometimes
play this move in the smith more but
never this early we want to develop our
pieces normally as we normally do in the
smith mora and we have massive control
we have total control over the square so
we want to start by getting the bishop
out
to c4
and we can also think about putting
early pressure on the f7 pawn we can do
that by getting the queen out to b3 i
think everybody's familiar with this
idea by now when the pawn on c2 is
sacrificed early queen b3 related ideas
become a thing
and speaking of which queen b3 here is
very possible but we could also amend
that
in a slightly more tactical way so what
is possible here on the theme of queen
b3
so we could start with bishop takes f7
check there's a very interesting line
there after queen b3 check
black can actually play d5
using the tempo that he has
while we're taking this bishop to shove
this pawn down to d4
so the crazy thing
is that i actually think
queen b3 might be better than bishop
takes f7 check in this particular
instance so we're actually going to go
queen b3 and after the game i'll show
you why i'm
insistent on playing it this way now
which piece do we want to recapture with
our opponent probably feels relieved
that we didn't take on f7 but i think
that this is much more likely to result
in a quick win well we definitely want
to take with the pawn we want to keep
the battery alive and we want to keep
the pressure on f7 in addition taking
with the pawn gives this dark squared
bishop a
very very powerful developing square on
a3 uh we could put the bishop there
right now but our opponent has left f7
hanging we're definitely taking that and
i'm thinking that we can follow up by
playing bishop a3 check
and this is gonna get
really dicey for black
really really fast okay so
this is not gg yet by the way this is
not quite as easy as it may appear
um as you'll see black has a couple of
defensive options
but i think if we develop properly um we
should be close to winning let's start
with bishop a3 check and then after d6
which is forced let's think
so
the first option would be to put more
pressure on the d6 pawn this seems like
a logical thing to do so probably some
of you are thinking let's go with d1
the problem with rook t1 is black has
knight takes e4
simultaneously taking that pawn and then
defending
d6
so we have to find a response to knight
takes e4
now i actually think that
the response to knight takes
okay there's a there's an interesting
line there that i'm trying to puzzle out
so rook 21964 is one option we could
investigate that further
the other option is
uh to simply develop our pieces we could
just play knight f3 and castle
and hold off on
uh attacking the d6 pawn until we're
fully developed but my intuition is
telling uh it's is telling me that rook
d1 has to be the move and there has to
be something after knight takes b4 we'll
figure out what it is
if black plays it but i'm just going to
go rook d1 intuitively and then we'll
cross that bridge if we get there
okay so we have gotten there
and this is i think an instructive
moment because most people are probably
thinking let's get rid of this knight so
you're thinking of f3 or queen d5 but
neither of these moves seems as
convincing to me as perhaps it does to
you because black will have ways of
counter-attacking the f7 bishop so for
example
if white plays f3
black has the nasty move queen out to f6
and then if you calculate f takes e4
queen takes f7
that is still a little bit uncertain but
in that line i actually think white is
able to transform the position into a
very favorable end game so f3
is
one very viable option let's just go f3
let's play this simple
in an actual over-the-board game i would
very seriously consider playing knight
f3 and just getting our pieces out
basically keeping the tension and then
trying to castle okay queen h4 check i
had a feeling that black would play this
but it's not good we go g3 and if black
takes on g3 and then there's just
checkmate on on d6
so let's see if black is able to figure
yeah he is able to figure out the best
move which is queen f6
and now i think that we have
okay so we've got a couple of options
here
um this is not gg yet i mean black is
somehow he's holding on which is
pretty incredible i think that we need
to transform our advantage right now we
have this attack what we need to do is
just take the knight on e4 and then take
the pawn on d6 either with the rooker
with the bishop and we'll probably end
up getting some sort of an end game
where we're up upon and we have a
tremendous initiative so
you got to be able to do that when
you're attacking and say okay
this form of the attack isn't working
out exactly like i wanted it to so we're
going to take the attack and then
transform it into a different type of
advantage now how should we take on d6
we have two approaches here the one hand
we could take with the bishop and then
collect black's pawns we could play
bishop takes and then bishop takes c5 on
the other hand we could say well i don't
care as much about the e5 pawn i care
more about
the initiative against black's king i
like brook takes d6 i feel like this
contains a lot more pizzazz because it
sets up a potential discovery
and it you know
we'll be able to win the e5 fund when we
want to that pawn on e5 is a sitting
duck we can get our knight out to f3
later i don't think we'll have a problem
winning that pawn i think we need to
make put the emphasis on quick
development and see how far that can get
us
okay queen takes p3 our opponent
continues to play this
pretty accurately a takes b3 and king e8
is correct also
okay so we need to get our knight out to
f3 and now after knight c6 black is
actually holding the balance
uh pretty nicely so let's complete our
development let's castle
and let's continue trying to put
pressure
on black in this endgame i'm very
impressed with our opponent's defensive
capabilities here maybe we should have
taken with the bishop after all but
something tells me that this position is
very very hard to play for black we have
a rook that's sandwiched on d6 and we
need to keep the attack going we cannot
waste time and we cannot let black keep
consolidating so what move allows us to
keep the initiative going this is a very
natural move to me
um because it creates a lot more threats
and that moves knight out to g5 exactly
so the knight can potentially
can potentially maneuver to e6 it can
also
uh go to f7 i mean there's a lot of
options here rook d8 so
here are very important to avoid taking
on d8 you might think oh we take on d8
and go knight f7 of the fork but after
rook takes the black intake back with
the knight then we won't be able to get
our knight into f7 so the way we want to
play this
is to go with the immediate knight f7
now this isn't exactly a fork because
obviously black plays rook takes d6 now
interesting question what do we
recapture with this is actually a very
tricky question
because i feel like some of you might
intuitively gravitate toward taking with
the bishop because it keeps the attack
on the rook on h a but if you calculate
that out bishop takes d6 black plays
rook g8 and yes we win the pawn on e5
but you have to remember that in the end
game an extra pawn isn't always the end
of the world and what's going to end up
happening is that you get an opposite
colored bishop end game where black is
able to get his pieces out a much better
option is to take with the knight for
two reasons first of all this is a fork
so we still are able to win a pawn but
the most important reason is that we
pave the way for the rook to infiltrate
to f7 which is exactly what we're gonna
do right now and we're gonna end up
winning a lot more than just one pawn
we're probably gonna end up winning two
pawns and we're gonna get a huge attack
against black's king
so which pawn do we take first well if
you compare we can take b7 with the rook
or we can take g7 of the rook
well think about it obviously we should
take g7 of the rook because that attacks
the bishop and then we can take b7 with
the knight in order to prevent black
from putting his rock on ffa notice what
black just did there he's trying to
checkmate us on f1 that's a tricky idea
but our bishop is preventing the rook
from coming to f8
so now knight takes b7 we've got our own
mating ideas knight c5 is very very
close to mate
so we should be able to finish this one
off pretty smoothly that knight on c6
has also
lost its supporting pawn so the move
rook c7 could end up
uh being very very strong the knight
simply doesn't have a lot of breathing
room or squares to go to does that make
sense
so black is down two pawns and we've got
the king fully surrounded king f6
and as we discussed where should the
rook go there's only one square
available to the rook and it's c7 right
it's literally the only move
literally the only move every other
square is controlled by black's pieces
d7 was controlled by the bishop
and now knight d8 loses on the spot i
won't tell you why just yet in case he
plays it
knight b8 is probably the only move for
black okay our opponent finds it
now in such positions
i mean on the one hand you know you have
to play
aggressively and actively but on the
other hand it's important not to rush
too much and to make improving moves
when possible so that we don't have to
worry about various headaches so this is
a good example right this king on g1
black has this constant idea of putting
a rook on f1 and checkmating us i don't
want to deal with that headache
particularly in time pressure so one
thing we could do to improve our
position is just get the king to e3 a
very safe central square and then we
could worry about picking up the rest of
black's pawns so we make our
improvements first this helps us survive
time pressure let's go king e3 forget
about everything else and then we're
gonna start worrying about bishop d6 and
knight back to c5 and other moves that
aim to win black's other pawns
this is a a nice
example of sort of russian school of
chess you can call it whatever you want
but it's this idea of not you know
making improvements first before you
uh before you barrel into complications
knight d7
okay
so lots of options lots of options here
we could go knight back to d6 and try to
go to f7 i like the the concept of
trading knights here since we're up two
pawns an opposite colored bishop end
game doesn't worry me too much i feel
like it's already going to be totally
winning
and we're very likely to win a third
pawn because black's got pawns all over
the board they're all scattered they're
all weak we're definitely going to win a
third pawn here okay knight b6 and case
in point we can take a seven and i'm
hoping that black plays rook d8 because
we have a really really pretty tactic if
rook d8 happens something tells me
though that he might play rook c8
okay so we have a third pawn in the bag
we've got connected passers which we can
start pushing on the very next move we
can play c4 and then we can move the
knight back and just keep pushing the c
pawn that's the simplest plan
very very simple i mean it's easy to
convert these end games if you don't
blunder anything goes rook a8 i mean
that plays right into our hands at this
point we're up three pawns and we're
actually even gonna be up four if you
think about it the e5 pawn is a total
sitting duck how can we combine our
bishop and knight in order to win the e5
pawn what two moves can we make in order
to go up four pawns yeah we can start
with knight d3 not knight d7 because the
bishop is covering that square
don't forget about these and now bishop
d6
and now we're up four pawns and the game
is over
knight d7 would have hung the knight
okay bishop takes e5 check
and that's it
now we start pushing our pawns in in no
particular order it doesn't really
matter i would even bring the king up to
d4 just uh to help supervise the
progress of the pawns and then we can
continue pushing c5 p4 we can push
indiscriminately all of our pieces are
defending each other we really don't
have to worry about anything else
just keep pushing v5 c5 c4 the only
thing is bishop e2 might happen and then
we're going to have to move our bishop
but
that's the only only threat that black
can make okay c5
and then c6 and then b6
okay this is
pretty easy and pretty fun
thank you burritos galore okay knight
takes c5 check and now we're also
winning the bishop on top of everything
else
that was a nice game that was not not
easy at all and our opponent defended
very very well so i'm sure that i
probably had
more efficient ways to win right out of
the opening but
we can we can take a look with an engine
actually we can take a look with an
engine just because this game in
particular i feel like there was a lot
of tactical
uh action
and it would be a good idea to see what
where i went wrong i'm sure i made quite
a few mistakes
uh and didn't exploit this in the best
way so let's see
um okay the accuracy is not bad
maybe it wasn't as bad as i
as i had thought
okay so let's see
so yeah e5 is is a big mistake
um
i don't know why it's like not giving me
the kind of review that i want okay
anyways um so queen b3 is one of the top
moves i i wanted to show why bishop
takes f7 check is wrong this is a very
instructive moment and i can already
tell by the eval bar that it's wrong so
i've shut down the computer lines for
the time being because i want people to
think of this on their own
okay so queen b3 check
now the way you might be thinking of
this is okay the king moves away we take
on b4 we've restored material equality
the king has lost castling rights we
have all of the advantages of our
position but in
this position black has a really cool
resource and if you were listening
carefully i actually mentioned it during
the game
black can play the move d5 and the way
that this works is well white has to
waste a tempo recapturing bishop because
we sacrificed it and while we do that
black pushes this pawn down to d4 maybe
actually black starts with knight c6 if
we look at the computer rebel yeah
knight c6 is a much better idea here
developing with tempo and if the queen
drops back to b3
trying to pin the pundit black has
knight d4 so all of a sudden black gets
this initiative because we had to waste
time capturing the bishop so this very
concrete tactical reason
uh actually means that bishop takes f7
is a bad move and queen b3 is correct as
you can see
okay so bishop c3 bc knight f6 and yeah
this is completely winning so bishop a3
check d6 rook d1 knight takes e4
and here
we didn't find the correct idea f3 is a
pretty significant mistake it's still
winning the best move though
was bishop back to d5
okay so here's what i missed i
completely forgot that we're also
attacking b7 i just forgot that that
pawn is hanging
i forgot that that pawn is saying the
reason i rejected bishop d5 is because
it blocks the rook's contact with the d6
pawn
and i didn't realize that it for example
in this line bishop c5 dc and then
bishop takes b7 wins the game because
it's an attack on the queen and an
attack on the rook
i just forgot about the b7 pawn this
just shows you how important it is not
to have not to be narrow-minded when
you're attacking and to pay attention to
all potential pressure points in the
position so bishop d5 is one winning
move the other is the same idea bishop
h5 and then bishop f3 again skewering
the knight in the b7 pawn so this b7
pawn is quite pivotal to to the correct
winning path
bishop d5 is a really nice move it's
it's very clinical very surgical
so f3 queen h4
g3 queen f6
and again f takes e4 mistake
you know at this point i had already
kind of settled on this end game and
this actually loses most of white's
advantage so not a good job converting
this by me
again we should have gone bishop d5 but
again i had forgotten about the b7 pawn
i wasn't looking at it this just shows
you that tunnel vision happens at my
level as well i completely tunnel vision
this position i wasn't even looking at
this pawn i forgot that the queen was
making contact with it and the other
winning move is bishop h5 and if knight
c5 oh my goodness rook takes d6 look at
that tactic
what a move
knight takes me through rook d8 is
checkmate
queen takes d6 queen f7 as checkmate
so the position had a lot more tactical
potential than i had realized
and uh this is
bishop h5 is winning on the spot black
has to give up the night
and it's over
and by the way folks uh knight takes g3
doesn't work because the bishop takes d6
and black has to give the queen up
so very instruct just shows you that
i don't know what this shows exactly but
i you know i had already kind of made up
my mind to go for this end game and i
thought white is like winning here when
in fact it's the advantage is quite
small
the advantage is quite small thank you a
voice for the two months and apparently
the move the only move to keep a black's
position under control is king f7
which looks completely counterintuitive
because it keeps the king on the f file
which looks counterproductive because
white's gonna castle but the point is
you go rookie eight
and if white castles you tuck the king
away on g8 it's like an artificial
castle and if white plays knight takes
c5
obviously you can't take because of
checkmate bishop h3
rook f2 and black is able to get all of
his pieces out knight c6 knight takes e6
rook takes e4 inter mezzo threatening
rookie one checkmate this is how
computers play and apparently black
equalizes here
so this is the obviously one of the
dangers of analyzing with an engine is
like now you think oh well this was all
pretty easy
i guess nobody's actually thinking that
though and king f7 is
not a move i would even expect the gm to
play i was positive that king e8 is the
only move
yeah brilliant line king f7 rook e8 all
of a sudden black artificially castles
with no other pieces developed and black
is just okay
so king e8 knight f3 and at this point
black's position sucks castles
bishop g4 bishop g4 is another
inaccuracy this allows the knight to get
into g5
and after knight f7 i think black never
had any more chances takes takes
and here i think we played very
accurately rook g7 bishop h3 knight b7
rook c7
king f2 and you notice that king f2 is
among the top moves so the computer also
approves of this kind of play
knight c5
yeah and i think we never really let
black go after that
well a lot was packed into those first
10 15 moves
a lot was fact into the first 10 15
moves oh 98
wait 98 here because of bishop e7 track
with a fork
there was a nice tactic a little bit
later on when we were already completely
winning i was hoping that black would go
rook d8
um can somebody find an elegant way to
win more material here obviously we can
take on h7 and this is completely
winning there's a cool little trick here
who sees it
yeah 96 check bishop takes c6 bishop b7
check with a fork
using both minor pieces to win the rook
that's actually kind of cool
um
so the moral of the story is that i i
made up my mind wait first of all don't
automatically go for these kinds of
tactics because they can be wrong
in this case queen b3 is correct
made up my mind too quickly about going
for that end game rather than evaluating
the options and looking at all sides of
the board when you're attacking and the
funny thing is i talk to my students
often about this this idea that when
you're attacking it's so easy to tunnel
vision
one side of the board and to forget that
something on the other side of the board
such as a hanging piece could
you know play a very direct role in the
attack one way or another because
obviously the board is interconnected
and i have a good example of one of my
games where i was able to
apply that and win
yeah so basically um it's it's a case of
attack on on both sides of the board so
i got this attacked down the h file as
you can see i push i started pushing my
h pawn in this position
and then i traded pawns i opened up the
h file and i got my pieces there so
after kg7 i did something cool
what who can tell me what is the fastest
way of getting a rook to the h file
this is a very straightforward concept
but just a as a little warm-up exercise
and obviously i'm ignoring the e7 pawn i
don't even know about that pawn
the only thing i care about is
getting the rook to the h file
so we take the horsey
forcing dc and now we just go knight e2
very good not bishop d3 mathematically
taking the knight is the fastest way
because this forces black to respond
okay so we get a rook to h1 so here it's
important to resist
the urge to give the check because it
actually helps black's king go where he
wants to go anyway
so we get the knight into the attack
and in this position i found a very very
nice tactic that's very directly based
on something on the other side of the
board
and i'll give you guys a chance to think
about this white to play and find a
crushing tactical blow on the king's
side there's just not that much that you
can do which i think helps people out
there's something on the king side that
white can do it's 96 e6 there's bishop
takes c6 and black survives
yeah very good knight takes g6
and the point is is this
if black plays king takes g6 and this is
where
uh the lesson is applied
we don't meet the king that's not the
point of the combination we go queen h5
check now all of a sudden we play e
takes f6 check
the queen on a5 is hanging and white
wins the queen
so noticing that queen is crucial and if
black plays knight takes g6 then we give
queen h7 check
and then we take the knight and we win
easily so something similar happened in
the game my opponent played b3
i basically ignored it i took it and
then played queen h5
bc king takes c2
knight takes g6 and now the sexiest move
of the game my opponent actually didn't
see this for some reason he was
expecting queen h7 check that's not what
i did though what did i do
um i played e6 check and he resigned
because the queen is lost on a5
so
the importance of
the other side of the board when you're
attacking
um is is it cannot be overstated
so back to the the speed run game full
board vision and here looking at the
pawn on b7
was critical playing bishop d5 noticing
that this pawn being hanging is the key
to the victory for white okay guys that
concludes the analysis
and uh i think that is going to conclude
the stream
hope you enjoyed
see you guys later thank you so much for
the support thanks for hanging out
everybody bye
[Music]